wir brauchen eine Aufarbeitung der
gesamten corona-krise und der
corona-maßnahmen mir geht es nicht so
sehr um den Begriff Schuld das kann man
definieren wie man will aber es geht mir
darum dass man sagt es sind Fehler
gemacht worden also das müsste
eingestanden werden in gewissen Umfang
und es müsste dann auch eingestanden
werden
dass man über das Ziel hinausgeschossen
ist dass man auch in eine Art
Kollektivismus verfallen ist in dem
kritische Stimmen kein Gehirn mehr
finden konnten das müsste dann auch dazu
führen in zweiter Linie dass man sagt
wie können wir diese Fehler nicht mehr
machen bzw vermeiden beim nächsten Mal
das ist soweit kommt also das wäre mir
entscheidend
das dass man irgendwie sagen kann für
einen kommende Krise wir werden nicht
wieder so weit in in diese in diese
ja in diese missliche Lage hineinkommen
sondern können das irgendwie vermeiden